It's another Mask.
I have to kill it.
At this distance,
it's perfect for shooting practice.
What?
Did I just say "practice"?
Right before murdering someone?
Wait, Masks aren't people.
Even so, maybe I'm losing my mind too?
Is she letting me go?
Whoa…
What?
I should've just shot her
without thinking so much!
You monster!
You…
She's not coming to kill me?
Is she feeling me out? Then…
Just to let you know, I'm jumping off now.
I totally give up now.
Seems like she understands.
-I'll jump now.
-I just need a good distraction.
We're so high up.
You know, it seems like
my big brother is in this world too.
If you see him, let him know that I died.
My name is… Yuri Honjo.
That's right.
Masks check to see
if they actually committed suicide.
This is the only chance I've got!
Take that!
I did it, but…
That hurts!
But I defeated that monster!
This pain is nothing!